hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my last airbender episode 4 video the
warriors of Kyoshi is the weekend and it
wouldn't be the weekend without cartoons
so naturally I thought it was time to
post a new one there's also a really
cool avatar related event coming up so
gallery nucleus on March 7th is gonna be
doing Nickelodeon sponsored Legend of
Korra last airbender art exhibit Mike
and Bryan are gonna be there tickets are
$5 at the door you don't have to make
any reservations but you can't buy
tickets in advance you just have to show
up get in line and it's first-come
first-serve the arts gonna be there till
March 21st so even if you can't make it
the night that Mike and Bryan are gonna
be there you can still go see the
artwork the last day that it's open Mike
and Bryan are also doing a Q&A panel
that's also first-come first-serve it's
in the Los Angeles area so if you're
within driving distance of Galerie
nucleus I'd recommend you check it out
it's gonna be one of the rare
opportunities to actually meet Mike and
Bryan outside of a convention okay so
moving on to Episode four business I
thought I'd mentioned just a few behind
the scenes facts like a few Easter eggs
about the episode upfront the fighting
style of the Kyoshi warriors is based on
ninjutsu taking your opponent's force
and using it against them in case you're
not beatles fans or you're not old
enough to remember it the scene where
Aang is running around in and out of
frame the the montage is based on hard
day's night the music video that The
Beatles made even though it sounds a
little silly I'll say careful for
spoilers from the episode so moving into
top five moments number five
welcome to Kyoshi Island so if you look
at the map of the avatar world Kyoshi
Island is right here it's part of the
earth Kingdom its main utility as being
a fishing port it was the place avatar
Kyoshi was born but it's not named
Kyoshi Island just because she was born
there
the kuvira so to speak of her time was
named chin the Conqueror he was trying
to conquer the earth Kingdom to in order
to stop him Kyoshi earth bended the
peninsula of her hometown away from the
mainland and thus it became Kyoshi
Island it's a good example of how
powerful the avatar can be it's like
we're eating the full blast from the
spirit vine gun you have bending you
have super bending you have super
awesome benders like Azula and then you
have the God level bending of the avatar
it's a little unclear why angahuan to
stop over he started to lose focus see
shiny objects gets distracted very
easily so you could argue that he
stopped because he wanted to ride the
giant koi he just remembers them from
his time or you could argue that it's an
avatar
thing and his previous life as avatar
kyoshi is what's drawing him to the
island unconsciously sometimes there are
those moments in episodes where Aang's
like I think I remember this from a
previous life but I bet that that goes
on all the time unconsciously you always
wonder what goes on in people's heads
it's a little easier to spell that out
in a comic book or a book with like a
thought bubble whenever it's animated
like this whenever it's visual on screen
you just kind of to fill their head with
thoughts that you think that they're
thinking so I do imagine when Aang sees
a lot of places he's thinking about them
through the context of his previous
lives even if he's not realizing it
number four
meet the Kyoshi warriors as the name
implies the Kyoshi warriors were an
order formed by avatar Kyoshi she saw
some women being mistreated by men so
she formed the order as a response to
that it all went down way before she
separated the peninsula from the
mainland so it was before it became
Kyoshi Island
the reason they continued to dress like
her is just to honor her memory and you
didn't need any special background to
join them you could come from any
discipline you could be a fisherwoman
you could be a housewife anything even
though there's a lot of missing data on
all the avatars I'd say of all the ones
that we do know about avatar Kyoshi was
the most proactive she formed the Kyoshi
warriors created Kyoshi Island and she
formed the Dai Li even though that kind
of went sideways we don't blame her for
that number three meet Suki newest
member of team avatar unofficially I
wouldn't say Suki officially joined Team
avatar till much later this was kind of
like her soft introduction to the group
and everyone was really bummed that she
didn't appear in legend of korra but
just look at the comics that's less of
the comic store for nyx the guitar she's
like the next strong female to be
introduced in the series even though
this is last airbender so it's mostly
focused on a male protagonist all the
women are still really strong I felt
kind of bad for Sokka in this episode
because they kind of use him to show how
women can be that strong gender roles
generally a really touchy subject no
matter how you address it obviously they
take the comedy route so Sokka totally
works well in that context and I totally
get why they had to make him sound so
dumb of all the cringe-worthy scenes
though I'd say the one where he first
goes to try and train with them like hey
I'm looking to work out probably my
favorite and if you are a little put off
by how Sokka goes so nuts in this
episode I mean you said to remember
they're like middle school age and
usually weirder when a middle
school-aged kid like someone who is 11
12 13 is really mature that's weird
usually you expect them to be really
inappropriate they don't really get into
it in this episode but Kyoshi warriors
one of their big skills is Chi blocking
which totally carried forward into
Legend of Korra obviously there are
people all over the world that practice
Chi blocking so you get a Mons cheap
lockers and their awesome costumes I
can't imagine that they stole that from
the Kyoshi warriors
number two surfer Aang rides the unagi
this is almost like another Beach
episode inside of an episode it does
feel like there were a lot of those in
Avatar like it wouldn't be a new season
or a new book of avatar without them
being on the beach doing something fun
the first time in the episode the unagi
is just he's you don't even know it's
called the unagi it's just a giant fish
with a giant fin sticking out so you
just left a wonder of what's underneath
the surface and Aang grunting across the
water trying to get away just like Corin
book three trying to run from the Sand
Shark if he thought about it he could
run on water if he was airbending his
feet just like a little bit although in
this context it looks a little bit more
like Roadrunner Bugs Bunny territory and
later in the episode I totally believed
that the avatar could form some sort of
low level spiritual connection with
other animals so I don't think it's too
crazy that he could get the unagi to
breathe water all over the town it's
just one of those things that they don't
have a lot of time to explain in a 22
minute episode in my number one moment
and learns what happens when you derp
your mission as the Avatar there is a
price to be paid for stepping off the
path and doesn't realize what's going on
till it flies over the town and sees it
burning but yeah when you get distracted
this is what happens it's a good
reminder of why this series didn't do
too many side episodes almost the entire
Kyoshi Island episode is them getting
sidetracked it can be a little
frustrating especially when you know at
the end point of the series is it and
you know what Aang has to do it's like
why are you spending all this time over
here when you need to go learn how to
waterbend but it's really these like
sidetracked moments where they were they
just argue about the relationship II
stuff or Aang tries to impress guitar
where their personalities come out so
you do need these it helps the audience
it helps us form connections with the
characters just because they're very
human moments they're things that we
would totally do I would totally try to
ride a giant koi to impress a girl I
mean who wouldn't
Zucco's barely in the episode he's just
there to remind you that there's this
other plot going on but all in all
some great fight scenes great firebender
vs Kyoshi warrior scenes it's a good way
to show off what good warriors they are
yes Zuko is able to take them down
pretty easily but you have to remember
of all the young characters he's one of
the few that's been extensively trained
in combat Aang is very powerful but he
is not trained in combat the way Zuko
has and the funny thing is is that the
episode ends with and getting the big
payoff you know he gets the affection
from Katara that he craves so much that
was probably the whole reason for him
stopping is that he just wanted that hug
from Katara
yes Kyoshi Island is a really important
place with some really important
characters that they needed to introduce
so this episode was necessary for them
to go there but do you think that if a
was able to get that hook from Katara if
he would have thought twice about
stopping I do feel like half the crazy
stuff that Aang does to get attention is
just to get attention from Katara not
everyone else just the girl that he has
a super duper crush on and I forget to
mention it during the beginning part but
another really cool thing in this
episode is use of avatar maps it might
sound funny but all the funny cartoony
maps in Legend of Korra are meant to
honor the really cartoony maps of Last
Airbender
I imagine Mike and Bryan envisioned like
really complex amazing looking maps but
it ended up looking like this so when it
came time to animate Legend of Korra it
was just like hey why don't we have fun
with this and make it look like last
year bender favorite map sequence from
either of the series though is from
Korra book 3 whenever they're first
looking for all the airbenders in the
earth Kingdom I think the only real
thumbs down I had in the episode was
Sokka being such a derp but I understand
why they did it that way the funny thing
when you think about it in the in the
beginning he has that really
cringe-worthy line where he says men are
more for the fighting is it later in the
episode he obviously ends up looking
like a pretty pretty woman if there's
any other fun stuff about the episode
that you guys really love be sure to
write it in the comments I'll post my
episode 5 video next week so be sure to
subscribe to get that too I'm kind of
happy that Game of Thrones is coming
back because it's a little more fantasy
avatars a little more fantasy so the
genres match up so we can have like
cartoons on Saturdays with Legend of
Korra Last Airbender and then on Sundays
we can have dragons with HBO Game of
Thrones stuff in case you haven't seen
it you can actually click here for the
Game of Thrones trailer and you can
click here for all my other Last
Airbender videos thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tomorrow
you
[Music]